there are times in my career i
definitely felt i had to be brave
and and make a decision and that was
you know the biggest one of course was
choosing to do television
i was so passionate about being a
theater actor
and when carson warner uh asked me to
consider doing uh the best friend in
sybil
i could i could tell just reading the
script that that role had something you
know she was really
witty and it was well written but i was
so ambivalent i
i lay awake the night before i had to
read for the network and i thought of
calling my agent saying
i can't get on the plane i just can't
get on that plane because it was a big
life decision i had children i didn't
want
ever to work in la it would have meant
working in la
so there were life decisions as well and
there was also that
feeling like do i really want to be a
television actress and
they only give you one script you know
it's only the pilot script and yet the
network wants you to sign on for
how many years five seven it
terrified me at the commitment of doing
it
but the script was written by a man
named chuck laurie
who was now one of the most successful
men in television history
and he wrote that row he
and i smelled it off the page that that
you know just the rhythm of it and the
the one-liners i thought you know i
think i could really do something with
this and
um the network actually didn't want me
the network head didn't want me
but i read for carsey warner in the
network and i
got the role and it opened up my career
like
suddenly i went from being a theater
actress to
an actor who you know the how ubiquitous
television is suddenly everybody was
seeing me was like who is this
new girl in town she was only like 41
years old
new girl in town but um yeah it opened
up my career and while i was doing civil
i got offered movie roles
and and so that was a a brave decision
a scary decision but one that i'm still
working for cbs
i am still working for that network and
it opened up not only television but
more important film roles so you know
it was a brave decision though yeah
you